Tatum
Acccel.
Oh what a nice little crossover
inside!
Pretty play.
Tatum,
drives down and throws it down!
Wow!
Look at him
and look at the look between Tatum.
This kid is absolutely
ready for prime time.
- Obviously, when your age comes up,
what people say is you're
so young but so good.
So, honestly, did you envision yourself
being this good at 20 years old?
I think the thing that got me to where I am is just my skill sets.
I was never the fastest or, you know, the most athletic.
As I started to get older and stronger and faster,
you know it just
kinda caught up with my skill level
which,I still got a long way to go, but for me
I just didn't think I would get this opportunity
on this big of a stage
as early as it is now.
- So now that you know where you're at at this moment,
how good will you be at 27?
I can't even imagine myself at 27.
What are you thinking about right now?
I can see your wheels turning.
Just how much more efficient
and polished I'll be.
How much bigger,
how much more basketball I will have played
and things I've been through that
will make me who I am at 27.
So uh,
I'm not in any rush to get older.
I like being young so uh,
when it happens it happens.
So just to put into perspective, Jayson's age,
you have been
alive the same amount of time
that Vince Carter has been a pro.
Is that, like, weird to hear?
Yeah.
Everybody likes to joke with me how young I am.
All of my teammates,
even Rob.
Rob Williams is a rookie,
I'm still the youngest guy on the team.
He just turned 21
a couple weeks ago so,
I don't turn 21 until March.
OK, now you said your teammates make fun of you.
I gotta take my opportunity to joke about something.
(laughs)
You said you're 20, you turn 21 in March,
obviously there was this funny moment
where you were trying to get into your 21-year-old club
(laughs)
and you weren't able to make it!
That's not what happened.
OK, no, explain what happened please.
This is your opportunity!
I was going in,
and then TMZ came out of nowhere
and he just started yelling like
"You know he's not,
he's not 21!"
And he just started making a big scene.
They made it look like I couldn't get in.
That was my last time ever
trying to go out.
I'm gonna wait until I turn 21.
Well we have a total gag gift for you.
Some funny little fake IDs.
(laughs)
So when you try to turn 21,
here, these are for you.
We have the McLovin ID.
We have your Drake ID.
(laughs)
I look like Drake?
- Yes.
You don't think you'd pass for an old man?
- It's funny to see how I might look with a beard.
They're not really gonna work but,
you can always try.